most of it was in the space of like
a month most of it i mean it was a
little bit traumatic
frankly danny tavares has seen
generations of her family wiped out
by covid19 this is one of the last times
that i think we
were all together as a family my uncle
dario
he passed away he was one of the first
in my personal family i've lost six
individuals
um four uncles and a brother and
and his and a half brother and his
mother
and so it's it's been
it's been extremely devastating what was
it like to see
covert 19 rip through your family that
fast
i i just didn't see
i didn't see it coming and the thing is
that you know as immigrants
a lot of people don't believe or they
think of themselves as invincible
or you know a lot of people don't pay
attention to the
the requirements it hasn't been easy to
cut through the grief
as a council member she's had a
community to care for
80 percent of people in her area of
prince george's county in maryland
were born abroad and they've been hit
the hardest
another diverse community in america
that continues to suffer
here a lot of people live in crowded
homes many don't have
health insurance and they work in
front-facing jobs that leave them
particularly exposed
that's led to a disproportionate number
of coded cases
and deaths denny believes the system in
the u.s
is still freezing them out to me
the fact that we don't have a
testing site in the zip code we don't
have a vaccine site
in the zip code to me speaks volumes
do you think these communities have been
deliberately squeezed out in the
vaccination process initially yes
not providing these vaccines
to this population cost
everybody we are your front line workers
we're your essential workers the
struggle in this country endures
life expectancy fell by a full year in
the us
in the first six months of 2020 but the
gap between
black and white americans is now at six
years
the widest it's been in more than 20.
it's devastating truly devastating
and i think that uh it sets us back
as a community i think it cost us money
it cost us generational wealth
you know again it's to me is part of the
structural racism
challenges that we continue to face
there is hope
despite the huge losses deaths are down
so two are infections but they've got a
long way to go
in a nation where faith is as deep as
inequity
cordelia lynch sky news maryland